Now that you've had experience writing
your own code and running it on your computer using IntelliJ,
you're ready to start on the final project for this class.
The project will be the complete code that we've started for a tic-tac-toe game.
Software developers work together on code all the time,
so this would be a good practice for working on other people's code.
Yeah. We'll go through the code we've written in a bit,
but first let's see how to play the game.
Tic-tac-toe game starts with a grid like this.
Three by three and players take turn,
putting an X or an O in one of the empty spots. I'll be X's.
I'll be O's. And then we take turns and two when we're trying to get three in
a row and we can do that diagonally, horizontally or vertically.
Since I'm X's, I'm going to go first.
And I win because
I got three in a row like that.
Oh man, I can't believe I didn't block that move.
And right now it's easy for us to tell that X has won
but this is the part of our tic-tac-toe program that's incomplete.
Our current code can't detect wins like we can.
So we need your help to write code that checks win conditions.
You'll use your knowledge that you've learned in the lessons to test
conditions and look for three X's or O's in a row.
Next you'll see this tic-tac-toe program in more detail and you'll see how to
download the code we've prepared and bring it into IntelliJ so that you can complete it.